say it ain't so Tesla virtue and scott
moir skate Canada's dream team and the
most decorated Olympic figure skaters of
all time officially announced their
retirement last night in this Twitter we
didn't know how to tell you but I guess
the best way for us is just to go where
we're most comfortable and to step away
from the sport I mean not before we pour
our hearts and souls into this rock the
ring tour we can't wait to go coast to
coast and celebrate this with all of you
just last month our Carlos Bustamante
sat down with the ice dancing stars
where they opened up about this final
tour and their future together fair
Tessa and I it's almost more stressful
preparing for the tour obviously perfect
for the Olympics is pretty stressful as
well and I'm not really in that
headspace anymore but this is just such
a different project and I just think for
us how lucky we are to be able to still
do the craft we love like for most
athletes after kind of the pinnacle of
their career it's just over we're still
feel so fortunate we have fans I want to
come out and watch us also we know what
it feels like to be the best and to be
our best yeah so anything less than that
ice just isn't okay and so it's it's
nice to challenge ourselves and new ways
how long have you been thinking about
this I mean a 20 plus year career
together obviously you must have had
lots of conversations about what's next
well we're still kind of having those
conversations history we really don't
know and when we reflect on our career
we we talked about I talked about lately
is how fortunate we've been we've always
been on the same page kind of goal wise
and we knew we want to be Olympic
champions and we work towards that and
accomplish it when we came back it was
shocking how much in the 22 years we
were on the same page and we're still
kind of you know we're such a team we
kind of work together to come up with
our future plan but there's a good
chance that that's separate the pair
hopes to capture the magic of their
incredible career in their solo they're
currently perfecting for Rock the rink
22 years and it's been I can't you I
can't put that into words and I think
that it'll be what our solo is all about
we've had together what we shared and
it's so beautiful I can't I can't don't
like again I'm not gonna be emotional my
first selfie video we ever I'm not gonna
cry them it's certainly gonna be an
emotional rollercoaster but knowing
Tessa and Scott they will leave it all
on the ice for their final goodbyes we
want to put on a great show I think
that's what Canadians deserve it's what
fans deserve and we're so excited to
dive into creating something with this
cast of phenomenal skaters that just
hasn't been done before and it's amazing
after 22 years of skating together that
there are still you know heights we're
looking to to climb